I think people is weird the way the
people see weakness so I'm not really
unusual like if you speak about it then
somehow that makes you weak I often
think speaking about weakness makes
people or your weaknesses makes people
stronger where test guts to do that
isn't it yeah it's also just you if you
need you acknowledge your weakness it
almost isn't the same weakness as it was
before
well you record no con yeah
vulnerability in general is a sign of
strength because the ones you have to
keep up the [__] pretense for the
rest of their life are the ones who are
living sad and they're the ones who are
truly we in my opinion anyway I mean you
can paint it any way you want really I
think some people justify it one way
where if they hide their weakness then
you're strong for hiding it but if you
show it you can also paint but I don't
feel like we personally know I know that
you know I think other people though
they like that sort of stoic character
the stiff upper lip I appreciate that
but if you're living in a if you're
living in hell then the this living in
being pissed off a little bit or not but
if you're living in a really horrible
state of mind then you have to talk
about the day are you ready to go me
yeah all right today we've got Richard
McCann on the show with us appreciate a
meeting anyway yeah why not of down on
the train I like stories that are sick
Alex success stories but even more than
that I like stories where people have
been through hard times and come out and
done really well for themselves and
you're a really great example of that
because I'm ginger I'm a that's it's a
it's a cross across the bay like in it
do you know it is how old are you you
know joking and 47 I'm nothing funny
[__] only you look young can you
believe that
come on ginger people age well jeez I
mean apparently forty seven million my
age
yeah thirty yeah bang on ish yeah late
twenties research yeah yeah no your I I
have been through some stuff yeah yeah
but you know I don't we all we've all
got things we've had to endure and
sometimes people hear my story Gore you
know and that's yeah you've been through
that I have been through some stuff but
not as bad as yours actually your stuffs
your stuff and the way that you feel
about that challenge whatever it is it
affects us all the same mmm
you know there's a relativity to isn't
that we don't think a lot of people
overlook the state I was reading
certainly the deal where someone was
like you know it perspective is a
tremendous thing like and it's how you
deal with what you're given in life
defines who you are not what happens
it's how do you respond to that
absolutely so just to give everyone a
bit of backstory do you want to start by
explaining and sort of what happened to
you when you were younger and then where
you've come yeah I think it's important
to see not just what happened when I was
five when it happened that the big thing
but even leading up to there things were
tough you know we were brought up on a
like many other people on a sinc estate
mmm I've deprived estate north Leeds and
we were on the outreach register you
know mom dad weren't doing a very good
job there was lots of alcohol there was
violence there was
I've got memories have been taken to the
social services to choose a toy for
Christmas because you know mum couldn't
afford think Oh baby they could have
fought it but they they drank all the
money that they had so we're a tough
time anyway but the defining moment for
me it was a week before my sixth
birthday and I'll never forget it you
know you don't forget things like this
when my sister mom had been out drinking
and my sister Sonya shook me awake and
she said Richard wake up mom was ah come
on let's go look for her we you know we
walked the streets looking for mum me
walk down a path on the field at the
back of the house in the darkness and we
sat and waited and unbeknownst to
anybody especially as was mom's body was
actually laying on the field and we'd
watch ads from where she lay she'd been
killed that night on her way home we
later discovered by you know Mosel no
him talk about Peter Sutcliffe who
became known as the author and that
thing that happened you know threatened
to understandably send me under you know
it was a massive bombshell my mom was
the only thing we had because dad left
when I was four and even know even as
I'm sharing it now it's still part of me
doesn't quite believe that that did
happen to my mom and I am part of this
massive thing that's you know in the
news every um he was been in the news
this week and but I am part of that and
it's just like a really surreal Junior
of being on do you when you look back on
that little boy does that almost seem
a different person to you in a weird way
it's almost like yeah when you watch a
computer game you see the character is
it a bit like that
yeah it's very much like that because
and maybe I've had to do that to kind of
just move on and leave it behind
yeah it's like happens it not just
happened as a kid you know think other
things other challenges that I've had
along the way yeah I know I know we're
going fast forward a little bit but 20
years ago was in prison and it's like
was I really prison yeah yeah was when I
look back on things happen to me as a
kid actually like I think myself I feel
sorry for that lot even though it's it's
me it doesn't feel like it's me and I
think I wish I could go to that like now
is the man I am and say oh it's gonna be
alright that like it's gonna you know me
and I'm sure that this young men
watching now who probably gone through
something tough and it does get better
like you're not I mean providing that
you do what you did which is find the
positives find a way through LinkedIn
post together today because today is is
a significant day because 20 years ago
today after coming out of prison I
reached rock bottom and I formed a
suicide part and assist there can't get
a job at least criminal record and I got
involved in drugs and but I was a
Thursday so I don't know this is going
out but on the Thursday in August at the
in August I got my final interview so we
didn't obviously through the suicide and
I got the final job so I went from final
jump you know just saw just that their
very last minute was about to lose
everything in fact end the life and got
given this job and it was a snap to turn
around for me that was what was 20 years
I get the message is however dark things
get however bleak things and appear you
know there is a way forward so as a
child after going through obviously the
worst that any any kid can go through at
that age you then did you go under 48
odd well dad separated Oh mom dad
separated when I was four so she was a
single mom mm-hmm I guess essentially we
went into a children's room to begin
with and we reunite with my father and
if I like a bit of stranger really but
the following year 1976 before you would
even born and we sit we step on the
father and his new girlfriend and I
guess that was the this
the next chapter in my life and that was
this the first time I can remember
trying it be positive because what that
little boy told himself was that mum had
been taken so they said I dealt with it
I've been taken by God I went to a
Catholic Primary School
the only Cathy who's gonna win sir but
I've been introduced to God I taught
myself as a and become six by now I've
done the stuff that got a tick him away
from all the beatings so that me and my
three sisters move it so that we could
have this lovely moon this that's the
create crazy things I tell myself so
that we could have this fresh doubt with
my dad and a new girlfriend and that's
what it's all for
and I course that's not true that's what
I told myself as a kid and it was like
me trying to find that riff sunshine in
that dark cloud and it certainly helps
me and be fair to say about my thinking
influenced where I am now and my sisters
without going to detail they didn't or
weren't able to think in that way and
you know you know their life hasn't
unfolded quite like miners submit know
what was him as we're starting the
podcasters it's not what happens it's
how you sort of think of it and it's how
you perceive that and it sounds a lot
Leah meant a lot of sort of twists or
turns because obviously you know if you
end up in prison
by 20 years yeah it wasn't as if
everything sort of went clean and no no
you think no your wife's like this
English it's not like that no yeah just
when things are going well bang
something else happens so while you're
going through a change of family and you
know with your dad there's this man who
did this horrible thing is still out
there and he's still nowhere that were
you well because normal was the first
this Yorkshire Ripper term wasn't even
known about because it was the first and
it wasn't until at the third person
today I have enriches and whose son I've
now coincidentally met it wasn't until
she died that then he was big became
known as this Yorkshire Ripper yeah I
was away and actually got attacked on
the way home and she got into a fight
that's all I was told but then as it
became this big news story I mean I I
had to grow up very quickly when I heard
these terms like prostitute and all this
stuff so I was very aware of what was
going on because it was such a massive
media thing and I even though it moved
to the other side of Leeds
people were starting to talk about it
and there was like some you know
recreate of the scene or other night
happened was on the news and then
whether neighbors were talking to me
about it so it was just and I had to
with before we started shooting then we
talked about little stiff upper lip I
had to pretend that I was kind of
alright with it
yeah they were all talking about in such
a easy way and it's like oh yeah okay
but the inside I was I was like oh my
mom is my woman and I'll see you're a
kid you don't quite understand the
context of all of that why someone will
go out there and do that or why you know
you know what good question
I've never thought about this interview
I've never once thought why he did it
yeah as a child or just thinking it was
happening it was like it was this big
demon out there and and if I got the
northeast connection him there was a guy
younger viewers what no it was a guy
pretended to be the Yorkshire if and he
said yes tip the oh we are say that
we're saying we are say Chuck I think so
he left the tape which was discovered by
the police of something it's anything to
the police and I remember I heard
because it's I'm Chuck yeah you're near
to catch me now they then you were four
years ago when I started and
grammatically yeah when you start was my
bloody mom yeah so growing up with all
this going on one I've tried to pretend
it didn't happen I was okay but inside
it wasn't I needed some help I said calm
the things a lot of people you know we
have stuff going on inside and we we
were is that stiff upper lip and we
don't wanna face up to these things and
but secondly it was this monster out
there and I thought it was gonna kill me
hmm as a kid yeah sometimes we think the
worst and I mean as much as I try to be
positive I can only imagine nightmares
and whatever else must have happened
because for me personally if someone had
done that I would have been terrified to
die I would have been thinking yeah well
it doesn't get any closer than your
mother and literally in the field but
not only that not many people know this
and must've looked into it in detail but
the fifth person to die was a sitting
you know a girl called Jim McDonald now
she lived on the same street that woody
wood that we live with me Mom she lived
seven houses away and she was a babysit
for us not the night one guy so when
June
killed it's like gin he must have been
watching the house for months he's
killed a baby sitting out and I thought
he's going to kill me and I've got this
memory so I was talking about seven or
eight now being left I was taken to a
local quarry in the local woods with my
father looking for some wood to build a
pigeon shed fill it off and because it
was a bit kind of dangerous
I was left at ground level where it was
you went down to get into the quarry
they all went to get this wood and I was
left on my own and I thought might it's
good luck he's been following me is
gonna get me now like a classic movie
scene almost sort of you're on your own
kid on your own just waiting for this
guy who's been like tail him and he was
obviously I just can I started screaming
hysterically he that comes ruining so
what I made up this story there was a
guy there that was gonna I can't mean
well what I actually said but I said a
guy had tried to attack minister and
that would have been looking back on it
I assume the trauma just coming out of
what you'd be in the fear the fear and
also because obviously that's not true
he wasn't there but because I wouldn't
get any counseling at the time yeah I
just kind of media that's a screaming as
a release us pause of some sort of all
the [__] that's going on inside
did you so who did you end up sharing it
with at the time because obviously it's
also your dad had left your mum or would
just you know yeah I decided to leave
the family where was your mum or
whatever the situation was and might say
you've got a new girlfriend by that
point so it's not like he's sort of
emotionally attached in the same way
that you're always attached to someone's
mother mm-hmm it must have because could
you talk about it with your dad because
that must be difficult for the new
person who's part of it yeah it was a
taboo subjects remember be fair to say
having now what the social services file
that they had a quite a turbulent
relationship so they did leave her after
all so yeah he didn't see her in a
positive light
hmm so she was never spoken about in a
positive way in fact in the feet on the
few occasions where I recall him
speaking about me mum it was like she
was a waste of space type of thing even
after oh yeah Wow so so it just wasn't
something we spoke about as a kid was
that something that you liked did you
buy into that or will you saw that don't
talk about mom
that way well what I never stand up to
my dad first a short so I might have
thought but understand doctor cause he
would've beat us to a pulp and he did
beat us to a pulp and I'm trying to
think about how I actually I just tried
to knuckle down and kind of alright
that's how you speaking about as well
sod it that seems like in spite of
rather than with do you know what I mean
like a pair and might in my mind a
parent even though my parents are
divorced and you know every night again
every divorced parent has that word
about that previous parent they you know
you you always think your parents a
supportive person and you like to think
that you know if if that one parent has
gone then the other one will be
supportive but is nothing that was never
the case for you it was not the case I
do believe my dad loved us all yeah but
he just didn't have the way with all the
the skills to not only bring up kids I
mean bring up kids is hard but fraught
for traumatized kids he just was not
equipped to do yeah and consequently we
we suffered some very brutal beatings at
hands my father you know was there a
reason for that like in history well I
guess in his mind he had done something
wrong alright that we had no money in
the house discipline is discipline so he
would beat you but there was occasions
where he would do something for nothing
I've got this memory have been in bed
single bed and my sister son is beside
me if they'd gone out drinking so Sonya
was left to babies anyway came in and he
came into the room midnight and he
leaned down and I thought was gonna kiss
his goodnight and he bit onto our noses
like that and I'll you know and then he
bit Sonya's nose so that's not about
discipline that's about power and
drunkenness and yeah they drowned the
dog in the bath they actually killed the
dog for a but in his eyes he his defense
when I challenged him 13 12 13 years ago
my first book came out I sat down and a
child in my father there is a man now
why he did some of those things and I
asked him about the dog killing the dog
I mean his reason for killing the dog
was it was a female it was a [__] and
it came into season when it came into
seize and all the dogs on this day would
try and me it with her right so I've got
this memory when back then when the pubs
used to show three o'clock on a Sunday
my dad being asleep in the store in the
living room had been drinking and Winnie
was scratching at the front door to get
in with a big pack of dogs behind so be
done was walking up a leaps out he pulls
the dog in it was a white dog so it was
filthy and he took it upstairs and I
thought it was just batting her you run
the bathroom they could hear the dog and
then it just went quiet and it took the
dog outside any bird in the backyard and
we never ever spoke about that I hated
him for that but when I sports him
twelve thirteen years ago about that
incident his defense wasn't now he grew
up in Northern Ireland and there the
family the McCann family be bred which
have turned out to be really successful
family of grounds they bred ground so if
the ground was not going to be
successful and some deformity they would
just drown the dog there and then so to
him in his little world that wasn't such
a severe thing and a bad thing as we
might see it and that was his defense I
think he was wrong did he look shocked
when you brought it up not shocked he
would try and defend himself though you
know you don't know because it's funny
because as I've become like a man in my
life I realized that the adults around
me who will like family and that an
extended family I'm like well you don't
realize how much I was [__] paying
attention usually you don't realize what
and he eight-year-old who switched on
can remember and and the word of advice
I would give to everyone out there who's
like maybe a parent or whatever or
thinking about it in the future
always respect kids because one day you
might wish you had have done because now
maybe in a big block and all that
there's a lot of people who wish they'd
been very nice to me sure I mean because
they looked at me as a skinny little
you're all in thought Isis but now like
people do and their estimate and I think
it sounds like you will heavily
underestimated as a young man yeah well
maybe I understand thing underestimated
in what way I think just not respected
I'm like yeah you know by you by your
dad at all like I can't work out I mean
I know you said you loved here and I've
got I don't disbelieve that in one
second but to do that it would chil this
sir it's one of the worst things to bait
them on the nose I guess
just Unger listen its nastiness yeah
there was other things you know that
what I'm going so for those things that
I did with in the family that were
horrific and for many years I carried a
lot of anger for my father hmm
and in fact I didn't have a great deal
to do with him I try to you know but
just that that bond that I used to see
with like friends or maybe even on TV
your father and something we just never
had it and in the late years when I
matured it was almost like the the the
balance was shifted and it was more of a
level playing field in fact not even
that I went the other way that I had to
teach him how to behave
you know I'm funny hope her kids end up
doing that yeah the parents what I'm
interested in is to me when people have
bad things happen to them that anger
that you can be left with can almost
drown you can imply consumed you can
overcome you yeah I knew you obviously
had something horrible done by the
strange man who you've never met before
to your mother
but also then you've got your dad
mistreating you did you feel any point
in your life like when you're a young
lad that this anger was taken over or
did you always find a way to deal with
it I won't say that I've ever felt that
anger was taking over but I'll be honest
here when I was a young man of 16 18 16
18 it I was actually violent to my
girlfriend I'm not saying a beat her up
I'm not saying to punish anybody but I
was I've got a memory of being drunk one
night and she pawed a drink of my head
and when we got outside I how many but
us to share this but it is what it is I
took a twig off a tree outside the
Marion said that leads and there was
like whacking her on the legs it was
only thing it was almost a bit jovial
but you know I should have been doing
those stupid yeah and and two guys came
over who were boxes and we're gonna
batter me and I'm here obviously snap to
have that but the worst I think the
worst thing that I did which borders on
violence I'm not making excuses here it
was me and my lack of being able to
contain that anger it was my girlfriend
I'm 19 no just come out of the arm he
got kicked out of the army she'd come
into a lot of money cause her dad died
and she was just and I moved in with her
and I think she's just given a few grand
awaits or whenever miss who wasn't our
cousins that wasn't work she wasted
their money and we we got into this
fight over the morning I think she had
some money and I found that she was
gonna blender and so we lived in a block
of flats seven floors up I wasn't gonna
do it but I'm a threat and that was
gonna throw out of the window
mm-hm and I think I was just not scared
and not to give her the bloody money but
she didn't know that and it kind of
settled down obvious I didn't do it I
didn't throw them near the window didn't
throw her out of the window but that
night her mum was there waiting for me
and she battered me with her shoe you
know when I came home well that's Sesame
though is is you weren't taught as a
young man through all of this as well
self-control and for me it took me quite
a lot of years to learn that and even
now Lawrence about fellas I still
struggle with it it's something I've
always had an issue with like temper but
one thing I did realize being a big lad
is if I don't get ahead of me Timber the
number if I do something stupid like
you've just described it could be worse
because I'm capable of like I'm strong
so I may think not thinking if I'd lose
control it could be very very bad so
that my fear of what I'm capable of led
me in take stock of things but I think
every lad at some point has a moment of
[__] another I better keep ahead of me
Sophia yeah I think a lot of people also
they underestimate I think it because a
strong male figure around the young man
can be quite important it's not
important it's not only about enforcing
what made what your boundaries are but
also showing someone what they're
capable of and then being able to sort
of control that like you say yeah and
that's what you didn't have as you heard
someone who's completely out of control
didn't come into it at all but it
doesn't sound like you are particularly
resentful of your father now or like you
are articulate I'm not resentful at all
we lost my dad three years ago mmm
yeah he just moved into his new his new
granny flat and he had pneumonia just
didn't got the doctors and his sister
found him on the stuff and what's really
gonna get bit deep now what's really mad
about my father
mmm-hmm I really I forgive him ten years
ago what's really mad about my dad and
him dying he's two weeks before he died
I'm in lead city center and he's outside
the stick and twist pull that was his
little local cheap beer and he's gonna
smoke outside and I saw him and I come
out this much I saw a cab back and they
often beat my Hornet give me a wave but
beats me I didn't see me and for the
footage often doesn't seem out I don't
leave I'll see you next time and I've
got this urge to pull over on double
yellow lines and up this front of this
pub and it's quite some steps across
this casino for core anyway and I said
dad I knew I said I was just going out
to here and to speak and he was asking
me about those that's not me rightfully
what she was doing at the time and then
for the first time and all his mates
were in the pool ball all he's gonna say
screw on his but his mates that I have
not seen me in a positive light because
I wrote about what he did to us and now
speak about it so I could feel them
Watchers but my dad stood up and for the
first time I knew his work to hug me so
we just hoped anyway I love you son I
still love you dad and that's the last
time I saw him but I pull like my I pull
off my can that day so do you believe in
I don't know like some things are meant
to be I do believe some things I meant
to be and I do believe there's some no
I'm not really just but I do believe the
Sun the soul thing going on that we
can't articulate around us that make
things bring people into you're kind of
on your journey and things happen and
and we'll get influenced by it maybe
those I don't know those are passed over
I don't know and none of us will ever
known so we get the plan do believe I've
had so many strange happenings or
throughout my journey which for me tell
me there's something bigger than all of
us taking place and in fact that crazy
thought is part of why mum died though
she did thought I was a kid that she
died for a reason and I still believe
that very deep level don't speak
you out very often but the truth is
that's what I believe and those thoughts
help me yeah no honestly some
mind-blowing things have happened I mean
that's a really good example my dad you
know having the urge to speech and that
deer and it's last time I saw him die
it's an incredibly sort of not to be
despairing about the stories and crazy
sort of messy story to put together
because there's so many different
strands they're sort of your mother side
the father side your own journey as well
in that is that why you decided sort of
write about it and maybe politically go
well together for you
the decision to it gets Messier the
decision to write about it it was
because my sister Sonya who was been
like a soul mate throughout my whole
journey we were the two eldest we went
looking for mum and you know we were we
needed up to talk we just look and we
knew what we meant and and she stabbed
the boyfriend right in self-defense a
violent boy for every man she's ever
date has been violence it felt I think I
my dear I'm at wrong the odd occasion
but for all my three sisters I think
almost every single man that they're
dated has turned out to be violent do
you know how they say you go for a man
like your father do you think that
there's something maybe this sort of
that yeah oh there may be some of that
but I think when they meet them and I'm
this have a lot of them they turn out to
be charming at the beginning right so
that that's probation abusive men though
is that's often you often find that with
abusive well yeah because he very they
know that they can't enter into the life
of the abusive so what they do is they
put on the shore get them to love them
and then the off shore yeah I'm still
covering I guess III got a four years
ago I got a text from what's one of my
sister's new boyfriends I didn't met the
guy text me hi it's John what his name
was a just wanted to let you know I'm
not a Cameron what words you use I'm not
a [__] and I just want your
permission or your approval today you
sister straight away red flag there you
know one texting you I'm not a [__]
definitely a [__] all right just
just that mean you know yeah and I want
your permission no yeah mmm so I said
how come I give you format but you don't
need my permission but how
could I give it not even knowing
anything about you turned out to be a
complete and utter waste of space and I
wish I had permission to share what
happened win back gentlemen but put it
this way he had just been released from
a sentence that he served well because
of what happened in reservations yeah
absolutely
right okay so so that I mean back to the
book the book was because my sister
stabbed a boyfriend she didn't kill him
and I thought okay I've had enough I've
had enough of that going through all
that and my sister's gonna go to prison
for stabbing this guy Mike Jack ain't
watch the whole journey now I've seen
the lack of support as kids my sister
leaving home at twelve thirteen it's
going to care cuz of beatings from me
dad I've been going into a you know
hospital and all this crap I thought
she's gonna she's gonna go to prison and
I thought enough soon off I want the
world to know what we've all experienced
but particularly her so I thought I'm
gonna tell the world what would being
through and actually the police drop the
charges
so the the need to write the book was
gone but through a chance meeting if the
are chance meetings on a holiday in
Spain met a guy that I written a book
about his life and I've got the nudge to
continue writing the book so that was
the reason I when I was researching us
to come across an article that daughter
how true it is because I take everything
I read with the pincher so I'll ask you
about one of your sisters it might have
been this sister wasn't happy about the
book being written or something I can
talk about that because she went into
public eye that's Donna my sister it's a
different system than the one you're
referring donut what can I say
she hated the fact that I'd bared my
soul and she went to town on me and
still goes to town on me all the time
Kashima I mean I read it briefly both
said some word that she disputed some of
the the things he said about your dad in
the book well she didn't say it wasn't
an [__] I think it's something along
the lines of he has redeeming qualities
or something like that yes and you know
what you're not speaking about him in
that way though to me generally exactly
how your Sutton spoke about them
actually she never read the book right
should I read the book based on that
[__] on Amazon and slag the book down
and everything she'd not read the book
and I'll stop there as to her motives
all I know is I speak from the Hat I
could write a hell of a lot more in that
book and I decided not to about other
people as well
and I thought it was an accurate and
balanced depiction of what my father did
well there you go cuz she never actually
took you to tusk on any detail in the
article no adult so it wasn't like she
said what he said this and he didn't do
though she I think how dare he was how
do you feel about writing a book that
some people might not want their story
shared like your dad your sister did you
just sort of well take a bit of a leap
and see you know what it is enough so no
fun no no no Donna in particular she
hardly featured in the book right I
didn't talk about it because I know what
she's like she's always been the same
way so and I don't list akin to a big
thing about Don abort now
she is how she is and it didn't surprise
me that she went to the media and she's
done some other things since um and you
know let's just say I've had to just
keep her at arm's length yeah I just I
just wanted to I just brought that up
not to try oh I've been doing me
research if someone out there goes and
researchers it I want you to being able
to answer that question when they
looking at it what one question that
it's thick you know this has three sides
to every story you know your side their
side and sort of the truth but okay I'm
not saying your version is not the truth
but I'm saying can you appreciate you
know what her wanting to be private or
her not wanting it to be out there
because you say you appreciate her side
of it and we we haven't discussed this
beforehand so I'm only asking
we literally don't talk we don't talk to
each other because it's impossible to do
a podcast afterwards you can you
appreciate everyone else's aspect of
maybe not wanting to share us or is that
something that you see I see it and to
some degree I can appreciate where she
believes her story has been I guess
publicized and that's what she's
concerned about all those other motives
as well all I can say is when I decided
to write the book my reasons for doing
so were honorable and I tried to do it
sensitively
bearing in mind that I went through life
pretending that what really took place
didn't happen I'll talk about my mom
here yeah so I lived a lie put on a
brave face and lying to girlfriends not
telling about it and it consumed me you
know I remember coming out in red rashes
when I just said something simple like
I've been to the cinema and I've got a
read thinking they're thinking I was
lying because I was living a lie so that
must mean no slope so all I can say is I
tried to do it sensitively
I am appreciative that she may not have
been happy with it but I've got to live
with the consequences of how that upset
her and I think for the greater good I'm
glad I did the book including how I
wrote about my father and you know I'm
there's a bit regret there but I'm still
a believer I did the right thing it
sounds a little bit like there's also
obviously her own grieving process there
and that sort of her struggling to come
to terms with maybe some of the details
in the book or some of the details of
what it might bring up she wasn't the
only one as well on mom's side of the
family some of them you know I've
written me off you know watch the hands
of me how's that been as an experience
for you it's been tough even even my
stepmom who brought us up you know she
I'm not welcome at her door anymore you
know there's been lots of backlash from
me going public and I think a lot of it
is that in their eyes anyway the
financial rewards I may have had because
of their story that's right it's quite a
cynical way of looking at it from your
family's perspective though isn't it
well some of them ever said to me well I
don't need to become a you know attack
on the family no I don't think it does
sound that way though I think I think
we're having an honest Alton discussion
where we're putting questions to that
people might want answered and maybe
they would want uncertain I think yeah
your answer and very open and honest
femur so hopefully yeah well I guess
because some of those people probably
will never speak to me again and I think
it's what I think is appropriate for to
say that's you know men will never speak
to me again because I wrote that book
and I'm suddenly one of them is no
longer with us but
her words to me were anybody any one of
us could have made money from the death
of Imam so that's all that was her
concern well actually that book was my
journey and now I went through life and
how I dealt with it and my mistakes and
so that I heard to hear that yeah
another other comments along the way you
know what even just yesterday on
Facebook I put a post on the fitter so
I've got my my own page and I've got
like a fan page where you got as many
followers
I thought something only because I was
obvious or struggling to post on there
is that sometimes I thought it wasn't so
I put a post on yes it's you just a test
because I'm having a few problems
putting things on Facebook and the
comment came back because we've no wants
to hear you [__] all right
so locks it all this person was it's
somebody from this state with that I
grew up on so I guess there isn't
mentioning this is because it still goes
on that that little cheaper win you
people don't want to see successful
people they want to find the cynics they
want to find a fall and you know they
don't want to see people it's easy for
me personally cuz I've thought about
writing the book one day and I've
mentioned I'd be in person because I've
had a lot of ups and downs in my life
before I ended up doing this and I
thought about what it would be like to
put well instantly all these questions
come into your mind of what do I mention
that do I mention this and then do you
yeah will this upset that person and I
think if you do write a book the only
way to do it is to just give as much as
you can in call all out there's no point
in in writing a book and leave and now a
lot of stories that because it may have
this person in that person you know and
otherwise if you even if you're gonna do
that then you make one not do the book
at all you know yeah they do it and do
it properly and do the lock or you don't
do it at all and now if I do one I think
that's the way I'll do it to be honest
the only thing I will say on that I'm
also the agree with you but what I will
say is when I published my first book it
has to go through a legal reading almost
so every kind of you know what's the
word contentious issue that could get
that could end up in court they have to
look right if I never can call what
evidence have you got who will be a
witness so when you say right everything
you just
publisher unless you got self-published
they will look at everything your rights
are published and I guess although
you're still in the same you still might
have been caught it's true you write
something like at the approvals you
defend it so I'll just make sure if I'm
writing about someone the can't afford
to sue as I guess yeah it's it's an
awkward one and I think to be fair
you've done the right thing yeah and
what was the feeling like when you first
decided to make up a who's that guy you
met in Spain but what can you say oh
yeah he was well they became famous in
his time Craig shergold
Craig shergold out our salsa holiday let
me tell you some of the best holidays
I've ever had
are those Sal's the holidays a lot of
girls if there's any males watching this
one top tips always take up a salsa
dancing I'm not joking some people use
it as a shortcut because it's a very
easy way to get close to other people
real rhythms I'm not saying that's the
reason you did it deejay salsa night in
my local town that's so the next pod
cousin is just me it was Padma the salsa
was that the pat pat me wanted to change
my circle of friends but also be nice
about to the numbers thing there's
mostly women that got salsa yeah so you
know I'm a male of the species and it
was it was a good period in life how do
we alter that you got away to crazy
without a lot me it's over
he also go on I know he we were all he
was a normal person
he was just attending with his mom not
again not the salsa holiday he doesn't
make this clear yeah and so we were on
Sol Sol about 200 people and there's
this guy who was around the pool in the
afternoon in a big scare down his school
with a medallion around his neck and I
actually time to do it I'll just speak
to random people me I'll sit them
so he wasn't without comfort of it tell
me story what's going on so I said then
I saw this is what you dressed as yeah
yeah anyway I said I said oh yeah my
name's Craig sure god I mean they get
his book of records I mean Google Craig
sure gold is got be hard it was dying of
cancer right it was in hospital and the
only thing
put a smile on his face was when someone
sent me get well card
so his mum put this shoutout please send
my son as many Get Well cards as you can
I think he's at 300 million he's a
proper 300 million at least all this
thing that goes on when he's anyway so
this is oh yeah my mum wrote a book
about me journey bearing in mind I'd
start write a book and then stops well I
really see then they make it a filament
of it now so when I know you I says a
normal story about the Get Well cards at
the sky by the way the scow was assumed
in America heard I heard about this guy
with cancer dying and they paid for this
operation in America and he survived so
wrote a book and I is a film and he can
get on YouTube so I thought that meeting
was one of those chance meetings where
somebody was placed in my path just to
give me the note just said let's meet
you mom introduced me the next in Marion
sure gold engine is ba' to her the next
day and she's friends with the careers
and all sorts extend along the woman and
that's all of my storm imagine in Peggy
Mitchell Arjun life character and I said
what it is I says I started writing a
book this year since I've stopped what
is it and I told her and she went
Richard you've got to write at that book
and I first thought
she's right yeah I'm gonna write in that
book so I came away I continued writing
it and that's how it came about so we've
we've raced forward a little bit there
from obviously you in your childhood and
the struggles that you went through to
write in the book in between that you
said you went to prison and you joined
the army join the army fist yeah cuz I
joined the army because so so basically
grew up with low self-esteem they're all
better than me all this stuff's gone
inside I'm not worthy it's basically
where I was at mmm let's go fled the
house to get away from my father at 16
and my first job after my first proper
job was ironing trousers in a factory of
what it's just a job and I didn't go
back to school for me exams I've got no
qualifications and then I did a job I
need to outsoar any jobs that was
washing plates in hotels was a kitchen
porter full-time and I thought there's
got to be more to life than this book my
husband cut us pause when I was a
teenager did delivering milk there have
been papers and I remember
sadly job butchers and so funny I did a
butcher's job on a weekend weekend but
do you know why it's really funny as I
can remember their pride used to send me
for the sandwiches they like 12 o'clock
12:30 so we made a print on me I don't
have a bunch of undernea and I'm walking
I thought ah unlike everybody else now
in fats I work in a job in a shop a nut
little kid myself
low self-esteem it was great an identity
a sense of identity as massive isn't it
fun especially when you've been through
somewhere people make you feel less than
them
I kinda know what you mean because I'm
when I on the weekend when I used to do
my six seven hours away over in the
butcher shop at the end of the day I'd
get me wages but I don't say what do you
get I'd get a 25 quid I mean this wasn't
that long ago even then I was preparing
for coral so all the sausages you can
eat for 25 quid knew him actually did
get a sausage or every day as well but
at the end of the day I remember Eagle
rates what what do you want for your
Sunday dinner because was on the
Saturday and I was out take a beef or
whatever and I'm gonna taking it home to
me man
mum that's a single mother on that and I
was like they God man did my bit and I
really made us feel like a provider look
in the young nature but yes sorry man so
so because I was going no I just
remembered that recently about the pride
that I felt without me so cuz I was like
a kitchen porter I thought nobody's well
one of them it's why did you join the
army when I was adding trails it was
Gary rhyme after my name check he wants
to join the armies he's a few years
older than me so because he wanted you I
respectfully wanted to join the army
together he couldn't gain cuz they
become a record for brain some London
hold of something Brittany as well got a
scare it went out drinking them doing
battery me one night and and then I was
gonna join on my own but I got to chew I
got I've got drunk one night and it got
bound over to keep the peace so because
I had that had to wait a year hey
venture I got into the army so the Royal
Artillery I was gonna and I can only
remember coming to London for the first
time to watch and
yeah I loved it I wasn't because nobody
knew about my past cuz a group in school
didn't say - about your mom being this
prostitute uh that's where that low
self-esteem so this was my opportunity
to start again they don't know living
the lie though and and I started that
journey and I cannot loved it and finish
it you anyway went out to Germany went
pear-shaped because sort of 89 now that
year Marshall Cavendish brought out a
magazine series which you might come
across it the murder case book series is
about prolific murderers and additional
almost Peter Sutcliffe and I said Peter
sucked if it was about the Yorkshire
Ripper the reason a pause there was this
week it was back in the news it's up in
the Northeast I wasn't there
it was back in the news and the
journalist rang me that we've got we've
got another Ripper story and I think
what when will the understand that that
word is a description of how he killed
his victims you know ripping and tearing
the flesh and a journalist you think
that I'm a bit sensitivity his name's
Peter Sutcliffe actually rather than
saying it's a ripper story it's like
it's no big deal to them but whoa I
didn't tell him I should I should I
should have said to her can you call him
by his name and and understand where
nough skids him it because it is quite
our imagine famous almost the status
thing as well like this quite well yeah
I mean serial killers in general they
have massive egos I I don't know I've
never watched an interview with the guy
but it wouldn't surprise as if that was
the case but from the journalists and
for the other people when you were
younger as well when you were talking
earlier talking around years if it was
no big deal and now the journalists who
know another like it just baffles me
that people be that careless
well she said to me we've got a cat see
what it is but I'm gonna ring you back
and tell you what it is really come on
the sofa so do you know what I'm
thinking about mind your expectations it
I probably won't do it because I've just
you know I've been interviewed to death
about the subject and
we cut pigeon old it upsets the family
and I she was back I'm gonna say it to
her
can you just bear in mind what you're
saying when you describe him in that way
his name's Peter so quick and and she
drew me back that day anyway so didn't
get the opportunity to do it I don't I
got into it yeah I'm getting onto that
because I call him by his name Peter
Sutcliffe but the shorter than the
magazine yeah and it was the Yorkshire
Ripper basic on the cover it and it
found its way back to Dortmund in
Germany where I was so one of my fellow
Gunners in Wilson for Milton Keynes if
it was possible for Milton Keynes you
wouldn't think that nowadays no no no I
wouldn't have been to Milton Keynes good
nine circles oh yeah you say that this
is you isn't it this is your mum and
from Leeds McCann and even mentions me
and Sonya
he was trying to choke my sister Sonya
through pen being a pimple is no
incident then so he knew it was me and
because my cover was blown it was that
was back when I started and you know not
feeling as good as them and you know
been Frank I went out on a drunken
rampage and I remember getting blotted
and I mean this is in Dortmund in know
not a Dogma because we were honor we
were we went out on a weekend exercise
because I was a signaler hours we've
lacked the officers and we went out for
a drink on the Friday night before the
exercise stacked on the Saturday and I
thought to myself cuz I'm on the radio's
the next day I better get back and get
me head down I don't know what came over
now into the open air and when the air
hit me multiplied the drunkenness body
throws me yes that does happen an
additional number thinking to myself
because that anger was there and I
thought I'm gonna leave my mark on
society like he left his mark on society
and I'm more talking about it because
and I went round this german village and
a smash defence ear and damaging cows in
carriages and make some more back I'm
kicking windmills down and I remember
thinking but all gonna wake up in the
morning or you know I'm all talking in
his little village like I was talking
about so cliff you know it all came out
and
I got basically placed onto a
psychiatric ward when they all came out
no they weren't
basically the discharged me I am unfit
for army service they said you must
agree I mean at that point you probably
weren't ready to you know do whatever
the army is supposed to do but if you're
going around acting like that putting a
gun in your hand isn't no I wasn't
you're right because I did have died
every furnace is about shooting them and
also so that does that seems it seems
like there's another layer to it for you
that you maybe did feel that it was the
route for you and you didn't yeah I
thought it was the route for me but what
I didn't realize evil it was like 15
years later is how it was still
affecting me a very deep level and yeah
it needed dealing with so yeah you're
probably right that the army life wasn't
for me so it was a good call and and I
did think to myself anyway I'm back with
my sister and I moved back in with Sonya
and that was that was that shot was at
89 and then in fact every cloud has a
silver lining
then my unit went to the first Gulf War
and I didn't go there and you know what
I'm glad I didn't go to the first Gulf
War because the stories after stories of
people have been affected by chemicals
and injections and all sorts of stuff
that I was kept away from it's pretty
shitty time for yeah yeah um is there
still lots going on out there for people
that don't get the support when it wants
to leave but that's oh that was the next
phase to my journey and I hit the club
scene and drinking and then eventually
drugs where did all this money come from
where'd the money come from for going
out clubbing and so I've got a job I've
always worked yeah yeah I've always
despite the loss of this team and even
despite some of the mistakes that I've
made I've always grafted because I've
always thought I've got to better myself
Pepa rounds milk rounds butcher's taxi
fur but you know I've always worked so
when I came back from the forces in fact
you know well before I got a job a
proper job I remember working for a
private detective agency hmm the two
pound fifty an hour I'd sit and watch
either women who were the husbands
didn't trust them or or people that was
suspicious of employees and I'll sit him
II can I got a little mini 400 quid on
it and
did that what would you say just let's
write down what they were doing mostly
the main buzzer yeah yeah they went into
this apartment at this time yeah I mean
shopping at Friedman's or an exciting
business or in here like quite exciting
to think and then you sort of go home
I'm just sitting in the car now what yes
mum's from 15 hour yeah make for a good
YouTube serious yeah I imagine some not
important that I eventually got a job in
a ladies where company in the warehouse
bless decision ever okay no do a lot so
we won't be going to understand women in
different way
yeah but you know what joking aside I
used to cause I was familiar with the
term like body suits another bits of
meat where I'd use there's a chat line
oh yeah that 90% viscose 8% LSD are we
talking about what yeah yeah got try
everything yeah yeah then the one wanna
be pulses way tix is like BMW Kaizen at
the bar and you say yeah it just just
drive in the night yes most women go oh
he's a hairdresser you compassion Ben
keeps coming up that's what used to be
fair my uncle actually for Christmas
gave me a despite a fact I've been a
four-year relationship now a Ferrari
keyring
doing best people the Ford Fiesta yeah
exactly yeah
did obviously I'm not gonna I don't want
to get too much into financials but do
families ever get anything after a
family members murders or anything like
that we didn't and she's a little story
they're one of my auntie's
said to us as we were growing up get
when you're 18 you'll get some
compensation you know yeah and when I
became 18 I went to see and there was
and this this hurt what the solicitor
said when he got back the decision you
said the criminal injuries board or
whatever it was called back then they
say if there is no financial loss
because of the death you're not entitled
to anything so forget the pain forget
the hardship if you get the drama
because you know financially worse off
because you lost you mom cause she was
on benefits and and also the fact that
you've worked since then you have an
active time off of work
no we're talking to make team saw but
what I'm saying it's okay if you had to
take three years off of work or three
months and then maybe they could have
argued that for you yeah but it's that's
sad isn't it the dog the only value is
the financial value exactly is like it's
wonder if that's still the case well
it's even got worse now I think really
you know having had some involvement
with this arena having supported
families and stuff for a set up a
support group
it's either worse now and you know
anybody gets criminal injuries to
compensation
yeah cutbacks everything we were talking
about I want to about to that working in
a warehouse mm-hmm because one of the
things that when I speak and useful
things I believe as well as every job
I've ever done even ironing trousers but
stuck in boxes I've tried to impress
that's try to shine I've tried to think
right how can I better myself here and
so yeah we're stuck in boxes but I
drafted and that paid off for me because
Grafton I got given opportunity from
this computer system in the warehouse
which enables he appear eyes and
eventually enabled to buy my own house
so which is why I'm from and even though
the numbers 10 grand a year and with the
overtime and the pit ended up having
like 17 grand a year so back then in
1990 oh that was 92 it was enough for me
to put up you know to get mortgage so I
got my first house those are things that
enable young people to get houses you
still go yeah well if you're in you've
got no chance of hey by the time I got
moved you know it was 20 for this
generation though they're up [__] creek
me why do you still have that house
would you start I still have the house
in fact yeah I rent it I've moved on
from there but still got the house and
just have a tenant leaves to go to sort
it out
is
in the Australian hey ho yeah Leeds
Leeds property market lease property
mark is actually alright cuz you've got
loads of students yeah but not where I'm
at something outskirts because because I
actually bought the house because when I
first came out of the army I'm all doing
with song you're initially and then got
a flat and I was like I remember getting
me a flat my own place and what I didn't
realize was right in the middle of a
crime hot spot I was like I think was
only person that worked in this block of
flats and I kept getting burgled and
[__] a VCR yeah I almost got the cat
pinched oh it's got so many stories from
outside because it was a metapod
occasion a cat and I found the cat like
three blocks away just to go just
Cavalier lovely oh they were actually
quite nice car yeah I don't remember the
speed about 50 quid for it and so yeah
so because I got burbled so often and
I've got to do something and I moved to
the outskirts of Leeds and I got this
little place but it's a little village
and you know what if you lot from that
village it was very quickly and some
people talk to you but the lads my age
you know the other a little scene that I
wasn't part of that if I forgot this
memory one day Boxing Day you believe in
karma adorned because I've seen a lot of
[__] do really well in life but I
think occasionally it can it can't
happen yet I was it was boxing day I was
in the bookies and I saw fifty quid I
saw some money on the floor the gang
stood on it and I'm having that so I
picked Hannah I picked it up put it my
pocket at what's out but then I thought
and I done the right thing you might I
mean is surely an asked him it he said
yes anyway so I rang out my sister says
Sonya I'm not sure if of them the right
thing here and I found fifty quid in the
book it's sure it was is you better give
it to it oh no it might not be a weight
on that night it's him a new house
Boxing Day and that night because the
house of decided pub one of the local
lots came out and it basically picked up
a tin of pain and just smash it through
a front window this is what I mean about
the locals not accepting me I wasn't one
of the one of
and but generally the excess was to get
the wing it was fifty wait it was fifty
bloody quid are you local the thing is
you don't know you might have never
picked up the fifty quid and you tell
the story differently because you still
have smashed the paint through the
window and you've just been fifty quid
down yeah what's what's interesting
about that individual who was a lead
spine particular incidentally and I saw
him just a few weeks ago going through
leads with his big maze and I'm letting
me Range Rover and and obviously I moved
on a little bit since then anyway oh
look he forgot what you forget is I was
looking at my bedroom window I wasn't
pissed like he was and I saw him do it
and if I yeah just not it's often
reinforced
yeah anyway so where will we go well
yeah mmmm bomb house despite the the
idiots that lived round there but around
this time I've got involved in drugs was
up the the rave scene but we danced on
the beach of Cleethorpes we've had a lot
of guests who ever said that before by
the way guess around your age who loved
going to the music community I don't
think there are gateway drugs
I think there's gateway raves and then
every drug story goes from there back in
the early 90s because everyone everyone
of drugs at that time yeah I mean I got
into it and I was the most anti drugs
drinking I mean I did drink but I
foolishly took a drap a speed off one of
the myths in the warehouse and I took it
and I could not believe it if it was I
was like wow it was like took off my
body's like bloody hell best dancer on
the planet chango's upon i it was you
know i speak about this it was it was
something that I found irresistible for
an inferno yeah absolutely
what in time is out after the drugs wore
off we crammed the eyes out then come
down and no hospital wouldn't have to
come down zone were that Mossad was
bugging to speed and oh yeah Bobby Dodd
struck over the week my dad's had
everything in try basically but speed
was one that he particularly enjoyed
more than the rest
wrecks your teeth but it's but yeah he
said it was he loved it it made a really
concentrated and productive and happy
surprise to play there's a price to pay
for all that but so you felt like you
are cutting all the losses up in your
home and good day I had this confidence
that I had not felt before and again I
became a little bit of a I was I was a
celebrity but was because it was so
appealing and I stood out a bit I
started wearing tartan
patent suits and tower and top hat so I
got a killer
Totten [__] toilet paper
if you're gonna embrace the the red head
and you're going down the right route oh
so you had a the thing is the guy we had
on I'm thinking specifically about
England's wolf of wallstreet podcast
that we did was following last my own
name yeah yeah he said he's a guy he had
some people still call him I need to
bring it up no cuz I feel bad because we
forgot his name
Atwood Sean at words come on Sean that
would just go for the weight cuz he
didn't know no so yeah he said he had a
similar lack of confidence I suppose
that you're referring to and once you
have this drug it almost inserts that
Indian you've supercharged
obviously it's false and it is that did
that lead you down a bad road then it
did and dealing drugs basically and you
know I was I was involved in it not in
the same level Sean was doing but I was
you know I was dealing drugs just got to
started promoting clubs and did
only I bought it pay for the weekend and
you lose him a job and I eventually got
did you lose your job for any reason in
particular or can you remember
I have to say that a lot of people got
made redundant the the place I work and
I got kept on by Stewart almost freaking
it wished you at the warehouse manager
gave me this stat was like a dad to me
and they kept me on but eventually I had
to go and you know probably influenced
his decision the fact that was you know
it wasn't stupid
so do you now look but so how did you
end up Gordon the prison was this the
start of that road would you say well
going to prison was the end of that road
yeah then it my taking journey which
lasted about three or four years so how
do you how did you get from the first
time you took speed to get locked up why
did I start dealing drugs well when you
taking them every weekend you know
you're gonna be amazed
somebody has to buy them I thought right
Jawa we need 20 pills I'll get the 20
pills and add a couple of quid or guidon
starts lud and then and really that's I
didn't get much bigger than that but in
the student please that there's a lot of
students in the club ceiling leads and
you know we were the locals so I'm gonna
find 50 and then it was like a hundred
name gets around yeah who's the one you
need oh but I think copper did approach
ones in an actor but you could tell you
you could tell by his shoes that they
weren't there weren't clubbers you know
anyway you know after care matters I
once dated a WPC and it was really kinda
strange but then she did a check on me
and see which actually isn't a love
adieu I don't think polo I believe so
but yes difficult to dispute that after
issues was there a little bit of a
dynamic day where you're like yeah
Oh long ways like that yeah it was an
interesting time getting your own buck
and how did it go from that well yeah so
I start taking notes but what's
interesting is that the right word is I
stopped I stopped dealing the drugs
because you know I lost my job that I
did a bit of promoting clubs and I
thought you know get back on the
straight and narrow here so stop taking
stuff stopped going out but a police
informer basically set me up mm-hmm and
said we'd like in fact I said 100 pills
didn't know I always think I was getting
like 20 30 40 50 well he came out so we
want hundred pills him and his dad and
his dad was no one why didn't I listen
to people
his dad was just got out of prison and
was a very serious player used to supply
Northern Ireland drugs in a big way and
they came to my house I remember the
convincing at whatever met his dad but
his dad was there and I came in and big
gangster type and he went round so 100
pills no I'm not getting involved in
that since I'll put you in touch with
the guy and we are not just yet we'll
come back in a few weeks so I'm back
working and I say nothing when I'm
speaking I get an hour to share me Stan
I don't give the detail that's cool man
so this is the detail is then if
something comes round about three four
weeks later right well I've Lausanne
drip pills and you know what I do I
should have like referred them on
because I knew instincts told me I'm
getting set up here but I didn't and
that's off I'll just get them and do it
that's it and also of your face and some
intermediate and blow you're just gonna
sort of try and make things go with the
floor what was interesting was he said
125 pills but 25 on the Thursday and
then I'll have the hundred on the Friday
so I met him on the wagon I've realised
cuz if he wanted them just take him off
me on the Thursday so I met on the
Thursday night it took the 25 were for
him for personal use
you're joking absolutely when the
hundred worth father set up for the set
up so then the next day on the Friday
get home from work
it rings me and says I love them now
and the stomach's churning I hid them
out in this country lane and I walks out
Mouse and this guy came it's a village
this guy walks past the [__] he's not
from around here
and a big bulging court officer the
camera they didn't have the tiny iPhone
cameras so he's walking around like we
get all flustered on it but it's got
like a strange lens sticking out of it
it's just just listen to me music get in
the car you know whiteness ghettoblaster
others genuinely I mean you're a bad
criminal but the police in your local
area son genuinely dog [__] like
terrible police so anyway anyway I
driving to lead city centre to
apparently this guy the the coach
station and I go into a bustling in my
Ford Ford Orion gear I recall Nigeria
Ford Orion gear now the Fords were the
coolest cars back about like cookware
the cars to have at that time right with
allies yeah Macau got pinched actually
first I'll admit his dealing from or
stolen the night ever after here you're
saying at the field
free time he's just Chuck's the Kazon
well I was by the timer yet but this
won't be here you had a lot of cars in
your time yeah the first cow was a
minion and I crashed it y'all I mean
badass to say this but we've been honest
here hmm
I was drink driving I was 18 and I got
pissed at my head and I drove the bloody
cat what on earth I don't know I got
home but I must have curbed it and he
spun it round and all the bottom fell
out and that's a scrap of cow but still
it's it
I bet some silly mistakes so the
ultimately you got to a stage where you
me at the ultimate mistake and was this
how you got lucky I got ready for that
uh-huh and what was it long that you got
certain Stu I got a year yeah so
actually what happened I thought I've
got off lightly and well how did you
find being locked up in general because
I suppose you've been through bad things
already in your life that did it feel
like you know that was parts of it that
were horrific but it wasn't that bad and
you know what and sometimes I'll do this
when something is put in front of me
prison or something else cares me I just
think about me more I think it can't be
as bad as losing your mum so I'm just
after wear a different hat go in there
and it could've been worse I you know I
could have got shipped out I've got a
job on the hospital wing yeah I think
it's interesting what you just said
there though is once again were taught
my perspective at the start it's how you
deal with what you're put through and if
if someone does go through something bad
and the overcome that it's great a draw
from that and have that strength and say
whatever you're faced with whether it's
speaking in front of thousands of people
or all these different things that
you've been through since then you know
you've been through worse yeah yeah so
it you gain confidence from that I think
that's greater you have the attitude
yeah yeah when you say it was horrific
which what happened
well I finally gather home himself that
wasn't that was a shocking path that was
a shocking thing to see and I was fished
with a guy that was it killed me for
what reason you know I believe this
I mean Lisa she'd stolen you car related
to the cancer going out on a weekend
I've got a DJ in the back and we'll go
to one whose club nights that was
promoting now I'll just nudge the cab
accident and I pull over to swap details
and this guy jumps out baseball but I've
get the baseball of oh no this is gonna
get nasty this and please just
coincidentally just drive past as I'm
this is gonna so I wave them down I
didn't have any insurance details it
turns out and what ya got booked he did
get locked up he got life sentence for
merging again leads right outside not
far from where I live it dragged a
Polish guy out of his car to pinch his
car and drove off with him and killed
him and that's what you've got a
sentence for so I haven't been on the
lookout for a man you'd well I don't
know if it I don't know the the sequence
of events all I know is it did that it
got arrested but it got life sentence
whilst I am in there so I'm on the
hospital wing of the prison he just gets
like life sentence when he get a life
sentence they put you in a Cell on the
hospital wing gavel your thoughts and
anyway so I'm going to give this guy's
is dinner and then they remember it
recognizes me from the guy that pulled
him over for the insurance thing when
your fourth I kill you it was like Jesus
and it's done / the guy inside cut his
face off but it was just scared its own
but a lot of guys well just kept me away
from him
and he was locked up in a cell anyway no
I'm down the corridors oh do people
because at that point in your life did
people know so friends did you say to
other people what your experience has
been did you share with anyone in prison
that you know so I I in became part of
what was the hospital wincleaner team
the sixth person we were in a six month
cell and yeah you
all came out and they didn't know and
they were sympathetic and so that that's
why I'm saying they looked after me yeah
hmm because there is that sort of
Barry's a bit of a hierarchy in prison
if you have suffered not I know this but
my read if you have suffered from a
crime like murder or something like that
then other prisoners will or might not
be lighter on you but there's a bit more
respect for your situation
generally there is and you're further
[__] since then since I've become a
speaker I've gone into many many prisons
speaking to inmates you know inspiring
them getting them to think differently
about not just their own journey and
what they might do in the future but
about their actions remember speaking
and Grendon on things Brendan Underwood
or Brendan anyway prison and I remember
70% of the inmates were murderers that
commit murder and it's a bloody tense
one hmm but because I'm going back to
your point about that respect because
I'd lost my mum too you know in
particular Peter Sutcliffe was quite a
high-profile thing that I had their
respect so they listen to me and he'd
also breathe in prison yes oh no that's
always like a joker up my sleeve when
that all comes out all of a sudden it's
like and we basically I got Phil to them
and I remember getting a letter from
somebody with a member of staff saying
there's an individual that's murdered
somebody I don't know the detail and had
never faced up to what he'd done under
consequences and the impact and after
hearing me share my story
he then what just not working on himself
and what he did that was just really
nice to hear that that having shared my
stuff it was helping him you know was
that what was that like walking into a
room full of people that he knew were
similar to the person that essentially
changed your life
it was tough it was hard but anew and or
safe hmm it makes me contemplate the
just the reasons why people do such
horrible things and you then walk in and
do you know a snake pit full of people
who somebody if they're aged so might
have been like sick and twisted and
premeditated but regardless have all
committed the same horrible act you know
and it just makes you wonder why anyone
would do these sort of things
I guess there's lots of different
reasons there's lots of different sets
of circumstances all of it was revenge
and some of it was and there's all sorts
of reasons why they were in there and
you know what I think if me sharing my
stuff to them just helps them because
eventually more some will get out
think about what they do it might stop
them you know lashing out whatever in
the future and that's the positive thing
then home and it was only about us
question teeth i how do you now feel
towards a Peter Sutcliffe and however
your how's your journey of your emotions
to attend on interesting question
they've fluctuated and I can remember my
sister Sonya when we I think what I came
out of the army I moved back in with her
initially we concocted a plan because
when she left home at twelve thirteen
she discovered that mom or dad were
married when she was born she changed
her name Sentinel mums name so she
wasn't Sonya McCann she was Tanya
Newlands so what would he say did she
was gonna do it she's gonna start
writing to Peter so cliff as a pen pal
we had all these pen pals and she's
gonna befriend him and then eventually
she was gonna go in and visit him and
basically try and kill him right so that
is what we felt you know that's you know
full of raw as raw as it gets no I mean
you between the two of you you cook that
up how was that sort of went about it
where does the nucleus of that idea
start did she come to you and say I want
him how does that start between two you
say you're quite close your almond you
know you are almost you know solid my
summers what yeah you're talking 25
years ago so I can't remember who
initiated yeah it's probably in some
drunken odd drugged state where we
thought would get revenge so I can't
really be sure about who I think it may
have been her that instigated that
knowing that she really was angry about
what had happened and she wasn't she was
the older one you know she was a year
older than me she was like the the
second one you know one woman sometimes
leavers do you think she was angry other
newer
I'm not sure if she was angrier I don't
know if that's the right way what I do
know is she was affected more in a
negative way by what we'd all been
through what why I haven't shared this
mum's boyfriend after dad left he abuse
on you which she kept to herself
and then when she told me in writing the
book and sitting down and having this
heart to her she told discloses to me
and it just explained everything about
her turbulent life about the way that
she behaved and conducting herself and
violent men and depression all that all
that her they all just made sense and it
just brought her to hear that and so you
you two concocted this plan which ever
seen everything never did never got off
the ground or so that's where we were
with regards to feelings about him and
that I imagine there is also something
quite empowering about knowing that you
could do that back to him or sort of do
something to him I wouldn't say that no
no as a time at the time I felt that
what felt that way because I would have
no acknowledgement Wow no I'd always
been through even the family know what
we went through was horrific I know that
they've probably knew that but we
weren't getting the support or the
counseling or so and then and through
society in fact we were abandoned it was
like I'll forget it I know that they
weren't forgetting about Peter sort of
good as always in the news but as far as
we were concerned as the children of my
mom no one was interested in us so I
guess it was like the revenge thing
wasn't it and getting some anomaly I
don't know it's all a bit messed no it's
true though because and now you mention
it is almost like it that it's written
from the bad guys perspective if the
headlines they're always about them
the bad guy it's never about the
innocent victims of this person you know
and I mean like after obviously the the
headline will read about the the victim
but the victims families have got to
live with that for the next for the rest
of their lives
that you know you're supposed to just go
along about your merry way now it's like
that generally sort of starting a phone
call we've got another Ripper story yeah
like that's again it's not it's not from
your perspective no and it's an
incredibly insensitive way to approach
anyone who's a larger Messala
I've had calls it quarter to midnight
you know it was a Daily Mirror might be
wrong on that one you know is that an
attack he's gonna die what do you think
I'm asleep you wake him you yeah but I
mean I'm partly to blame for that
because when the book came out 12 13
years ago obviously we had publicity and
an interaction with the media so you're
still on that I'm sound goes we've got
him on a file somewhere
oh come on a file I get it all the time
and this guy's he's outside what do you
think and I think even the answer was
expected because I said I'm sorry to
hear that
yeah I'm sorry to hear that
because he's got family and he's a human
being he's gonna die so that's what I
said they didn't put that in the papers
so what I'm saying that is it my
thoughts about him I've changed in those
in the years that I've had to think
about what he did and and and you know
live my life and how have they changed
is that been mostly down to you or have
you sought counseling or well I've
sought counseling over the years but
that was many to do with my failed
relationships because I'd always ruined
them I always pushed people away because
even though I had lots of relationships
because almost addicted to get into
relationship and just feeling loved and
worthy I'm not I'd normally push them
away because really deep down I didn't
feel good enough because of all that's
[__] you know a little I so you're
looking for the answer which is the new
girlfriend but really the real answer is
in you yeah that's the real issue that
was before so that's why I went for the
counseling
yeah and that was I can't know what use
that word but anyways 15-20 years gone
yeah
the the change in respect of Peter
Sutcliffe it was in fact it was later
going into prisons mainly when I go into
prisons when I have gone into prisons it
was through the forgiveness project but
if you do well you probably won't be
aware of the Fatima's project but what
this project is is it's just a
collection of stories of people that
have been harmed wronged in some way and
then the victim would then give their
opinion on forgiveness one way or
another so I was so had an interesting
story and I became one of their stories
and they would take a you know what of a
storyteller into prison share their
story and then I would go underneath it
spend three days with the inmates
looking at their joy as part of that
incident they had not forgiven him yeah
but as part of that involvement I was
invited to London in 2010 to their first
inaugural lecture by Archbishop Desmond
Tutu and he spoke about forgiveness and
it was that day that I decided I was no
longer going to feel anger towards him I
would just let it go and you know my
interpretation of forgiveness and is
what I did that day and I'm not
resentful I'm not angry and when I got a
call to say that he's dying what do you
think is why I was able to say well I'm
sorry to hear that
I'm genuinely sorry to hear that and
when they said he was going back into
prison up in the Northeast what'd you
think about that well I went okay
I'm not gonna celebrate that doesn't
change anything so if that's what would
the authorities have decided then that's
it you've let it you've let it go source
because it as close as you can tell so
they can yeah and to feel nothing rather
than anything because part of it is I'd
imagine
oh I mean I don't really know about the
mindset of a killer but that power they
have over other people to make them feel
that way and the influence have been
able to do that to someone else so the
forgiveness is ultimately sort of taking
the power away from it absolutely yeah
well that's all they have left isn't it
when they're in doctors and they're not
gonna sell they can't carry on killing
sort the only sick and twisted thing
they've got left is that how did you
feel about people writing letters to him
or his status as a not
sex symbol but sort of a symbol to some
women because that must be quite
difficult that did anger me yeah over
the years and I've not heard anything
recently but I remember back in 2005
there's a woman apparently going to
marry him yeah I remember it and if I
will make it a BBC documentary at the
time and it's one of the things that we
spoke about on this thing that's why I
remember it and I was thinking goodness
sake you gonna marry him
that's how I felt at the time yeah do
you not understand what he did and
anyway it's funny Larry you know lost
Sidious like that though as well like
what mean we had a guy who doesn't have
20 odd years on death row on the show I
thought he was an innocent man but he he
said he'd get laid all the time just for
being on death row like you know the
women they're all women out there who
are attracted to that for some strange
reason it's bizarre that I found bizarre
strange it's the TV show TV show is
called death for all housewives and [__]
like this one yeah it's the
commodification about though and that
maybe it's also really unfortunate to
you me you went through this maybe it's
fortunate because the way you've ended
up but they it is unfortunate or a
byproduct of the modern media that there
isn't really any escape 100% away from a
front page of that or you turn on BBC
News and them saying an update on yeah
or because you can't it's not you can
just mute those specific things and
because it everywhere you can't really
ever a hundred percent step away from
that no and I accept that now it's used
part of my journeys pavel i am and and
good about how I felt as a killer I felt
like I was in some kind of film that's
how it still feels it feels surreal and
wasn't strange about it is I'm just like
you understand all the guy yeah and I
still pinch myself thinking I'm right in
the middle of this I suppose it's this
because of the meed have been on to me
again and how do you feel about how do
you still talk to the media right now so
me
well well I do and I did only invite me
on to the the ITV and I said no but then
I made of the way the world now I made a
Twitter video on periscope
he made it Center six twenty past six it
was on my local news yeah goodness me a
problem with that because I guess I was
giving them what they want to be not me
I'm to go into the TV station but my
point on that one was because what this
story was was he being us by the ITV did
you kill any men or did you attack any
men
I wonder which I've met one of the guys
that survived and his response and this
is the thing they wanted a reaction from
me on was he brought yes I did some bad
things by didn't kill any men I want you
to know that so they were saying to me
he said they did some bad things what do
you think about that
and I said you know what yeah that's the
first time that we've had any
acknowledgement from him that he what he
did was wrong and bad it wasn't like
voices from God it was a bad thing so I
think that's a step forward and thus I
welcome him acknowledging that so for
those two for the public or the media to
expect him to say what I did was
horrific and I'm it's not happen
well because guys a guy with no empathy
people who commit these crimes in the
first place of so-called
exactly they've got nothing in the heart
that they'll never be able to fully
repent for because there's nothing there
to draw from to do that in my opinion oh
yeah I think you spawn and I accept that
now so were they when he writes that a
thing finer from him that's that's a
good thing do you do you sort of believe
in that he isn't a good person is that
is that the way that you see him or how
do you see him as a person because I
after I'm often quite troubled by
hearing you know the someone's good or
someone's bad because I also think that
sometimes that can draw people towards
living that sort of lifestyle they want
they think I want to be a bad person
that's going in my identity
I think what I did was wrong
yeah I think what I did was bad horrific
but I think the guys he'll you not even
going Ospital I think the guy is just
not mentally ill it mentally insult to
some degree I remember reading something
about the police when they interviewed
him in The Times they let him go nine
time didn't they remember yeah but
anyway and then I remember really
something about his eyes being black and
they're almost like soulless because
there's something about him that's just
not the same as you I do you believe do
you believe that stuff or deve and I'm
not saying your experience is any less
because I don't know anything or nothing
about it do you believe that stuff or do
you think there is a sort of you know in
the same way with terrace where they go
well you could always see it or do you
actually believe that he and you can
stop me at any time bad or ill I know
people say is it bad I realize I think
it's all the same thing they almost made
him do bad things how much you know
about him now and is it stuff you want
to know do you go out of your way to
find that stuff out do I need more yeah
I did but I didn't meet his doctor I met
one of his doctors who because I did
write to Peter Sutcliffe over the years
and written him twice one because when a
book first came out I wanted to meet the
guy and I wanted answers I wanted to
know why you did what you did and I
think that was naive knowing what I know
now cuz he ain't gonna tell you in fact
it probably do some damage if I met the
guy if anything he enjoys that side of
ya that power but then when I forgave
him not miss me and what he's made by
the way I'm on about my own let that
anger go I did consider whether or not I
wanted to let him know that because I
thought maybe there's a slight advantage
to let him know that I'm not angry at
what he did there's a slight sort of
checkmate feeling there isn't no no no
not not checkmate like the situation is
what it is I is in prison
I have lost my mom and I'm yet on life
that's it but if you look at the whole
situation I just thought to myself if
I'm late Gor if I can tell him and he
appreciates that and maybe I was naive
maybe there's an advantage to that
maybe there's an advantage and I say him
not me but maybe that's the thing I
should be doing them letting him know
like the greater good sort of yeah yeah
the greater good and the fact that your
mind can even take you to that place
Mayor speaks volumes about the type of
person that you are because I don't
think many people would be able to go
from the level that you went from an
opinion that you were in to even
contemplate that so the fact that you
can even think about letting him know
that says a lot about you so I think you
don't even need to go there
general I'm saying in my opinion anyway
one thing I do think is potentially a
good thing is if this was ever going to
happen to you it's I don't know admit
you let me know if I'm right or wrong
and thinking this but haven't happened
at such a young age might have been
better than being a 13 14 US 18 year old
absolutely because I didn't really
appreciate the detail of wound on it had
i been a bit older it's amazing how kids
can recover from things as well and that
you know you've you've done a good job
of that did you um thank you when did
you did you look into it like at what
point did you be because it's there's
almost a human curiosity there isn't
there of what why things out the way
there and what happened yeah over the
years and I'm maybe 20 years ago when
there's lot of books written about him I
did look into his circumstances and what
might have happened that would bring him
to that point yeah and there are some
things and I'm not making excuses for
him but there are some things that
happen in his life but you can see oh
yeah that probably did influence him day
like the dominoes that you look for yeah
like he did go or attempt to go with a
prostitute and I think he couldn't get
an erection and she she teased and
bullied him when it was young that
happened hmm so they did that that's a
seed planting for this anger and I know
it's wrong but you can see that oh yeah
and then he idolized his mum who
apparently was trying to be unfaithful
with a friend of his dad's or something
and then the dad set them up the dad
went and sat on waited for the moment
arrived at this pub and brought the kids
with him so he
there's some messy things yeah that
damaged him you sent yourself Thor in my
in my opinion with sick and twisted
people they're always going to lash out
at someone it's just sometimes this life
event that makes it this particular kind
of person like I don't know there's
people out there who want to kill a lot
of people for skin color or whyever
general I mean because they've had one
bad experience or but work on it doesn't
make it excusable to do something so
disgusting no it doesn't but I'm just
I'm just kicking this about now and
you're thinking about this but maybe
Richard 20 years ago was looking for
reasons behind what he did so it it
can't be possible it's just completely
bad because that's harder to accept if
there's some kind of reasons that led up
to it well that's a bit easy to do you
want to make sense of it yeah I think
there is also a big problem with the the
fact that it is it feels like such a
rare thing and actually murder is a bit
more common maybe than people realize
because we sensationalize a lot around
murder maybe we just remember one or two
things because the media cover it in a
certain way that makes them exceptional
people and from hearing your story and
actually hearing how often use of you
know thought about maybe having a gun
and killing other people or planning to
go and do something to him there's a
very fine line in your life very often
where you could have gone the other
route
absolutely and how unexceptional that
actually makes a murderer because or
someone who can kill their know they are
different but there isn't there's a very
fine line between the two there is and
what I haven't said is when I was
growing up before he was caught I was
having fantasies about going killing men
yeah I'll go say what I'll do I'll go
run down men I will go attack men that's
what I thought about as a kid that that
was because of cuz I'd always anger
inside so there is a no I could have
done that yeah interestingly I'm reading
a book by a marrying and Partington
marian's dots or mine sister was killed
by Fred West or the West's
and she was able to find forgiveness
I met her actually and she said when she
realized that she had the capacity to
murder herself because of the rage that
she felt she then realized that she
could find it within her to to let it go
as well and I we all of the capacity you
talked about you being a big guy in you
know you got to watch what you owe you
well I sure I watch something yesterday
I thought I clicked on it was on a new
channel it was a Russian guy that had
taken a flying kick against a wrestler
they got into an argument over sport was
better or and killed him so we've all
got the potential oh yeah
we're talking extremes II but I
understand what you mean because to
understand something is to upper to
really accept them like move forward
it's that empathy level of it though as
well I think or maybe not empathy but
that sort of some people have or maybe
go on that journey together the point
where they feel them connected to me was
you talk about good and bad people I
think it's like a spectrum I think you
know or there is there is one extreme in
another and a lot of people fall in the
middle or whatever but I think when it
comes to people who do these acts I
don't really feel like they run there I
feel like there's a let you say it ill
like this this sick and twisted people
who don't understand what they doing is
right or wrong or it's just what they
want to do you know and I don't think
that they're aware of this is good this
is bad and the impact no yeah and that's
why there's no empathy personally that's
the way our view of them anyway but yeah
you know you got me thinking about
things here you know like going through
life that the jobs that I've had I've
always tried to be the best cuz that's
good to me because I might get a
promotion I think there's a similar
thing going on here cuz it if I'm angry
about what he did and that's
understandable and it's a natural thing
as well but if I can't find empathy or
forgiveness that's good for me yeah
and I think I've taken a lot and I'm
nearly 50 Anna I take a long time to
come to that understanding but letting
things go forgiveness it's it's not how
you might think it's not right I'll
forgive you I mean that can be a level
of forgiveness put me around your let's
shake no for me it's about letting it go
not letting that person dictate how I
feel about life and about what you've
done you know what it's done now let it
go I'm moving on I've got the old family
now but you have I've got I got
beautiful thing that happened a few
months ago my son little boy turned I
mean they're aware of what took place
hmm with their grandma and we speak
about in quite often and he's also a way
I want them to be aware of the
forgiveness side of it mm-hmm it's been
a big part of my journey
and I was speaking for West Yorkshire
police about three months ago and I said
Oh son I'm speaking for West Yorkshire
police don't that be interesting good
why of course it was a system is that
his name right so I said then well it
was wished Yorkshire police that were
looking for him because there's
different police force he's right you
know
and he turned around and he stopped me
in my tracks his dad you know what he
says I think I forgive him I said why
not I've had a bad childhood
I mean he said it might have had his mom
killed yeah I said well actually didn't
have his mum killed I said but that's a
beautiful thing to say you know for my
kids to have that understanding about
the power of forgiveness and letting
things go thing as a message to
beautiful thing how often do you asked
sorry
no I just I empathize with what you soon
because I had a lot of anger towards a
person once in my life and I did
contemplate going to talk to them about
it because I thought this is [__]
eating me alive yeah
just a chat yeah and just to sit and
just to try and sort it out although
they didn't deserve that but I just
thought if this is gonna [__] take
over me I cuz I actually wanted to like
beat the [__] out of someone it won't
play like to the point of I guess kill
them like generally I really I hated
them that much like if you told me
they'd been hit by a bus I would be like
the [__] great
made my [__] day that like I would
have been like that and I thought this
isn't healthy so I did think about gonna
but eventually I came to my own
conclusion of that's actually not they
don't deserve that in its and it
wouldn't be
understood or reciprocated from there
and so it's not going to benefit me to
go there and try and do that but letting
it go I don't know if I'd say
forgiveness but letting it go is a
really healthy thing for everyone to do
like cuz holdin on to anger and that it
really doesn't help your life and
ultimately well one I have a good
[__] life do you not I mean no it
must be very frustrating for you as
someone as well though there because
there are also a lot of people who will
you've told your own story but not
everyone's gonna need your book there
are a lot of people who also want to
call most co-opt your story a little bit
and tell it you know there's a lot of
people who want to write about him a lot
people that want to write about your
story your aspect of that journalist
call you they want to you know they
might take your words and spin them in a
way how do you feel about that you know
the journalists because like you say
those gymnasts are all looking for
quotes and you might go work actually I
feel all right about it and they'll go
next or not yeah next yeah exactly one
we can call who's been in this source
had you feel about other people taking
that story and trying to spin it to make
it their own
you know maybe their own front page your
own sensational side how do I feel I've
just I've grown up watching almost
weekly stories about him so then you
know phoning me and they're not using
what I have to say cuz it doesn't meet
the headlines that they want to put out
there ah you know what when you compare
things what's happened let them get on
with it yeah you know it's just I think
we're all aware of what the media do
it's almost inconsequential in a sense
towards your bigger book great no today
yeah I guess in a way is also pushing
people towards maybe seeking out your
story and you know well the thing is I'm
a bit of a a watcher and I know a lot of
people do of documentaries about serial
killers and all of that because they are
seen is totally different and I find
interesting
of course on jinan I mean I do like
actually enjoy watching them because I
want famous programs in general I find
them fascinating Siddhant but since
meeting you today I'll always watch them
a bit differently from now on because
I'll always think more about the victims
of what they went in did
you get in all the gory details and you
know the police tried to catch him and
you think more about that then the
people who are left behind the the
victims of the crime who were left
behind you know means obviously one is
it Marilyn the girl who was she was on
holiday uh my name is she was an
American girl who was accused of killing
another girl I'm sort of sex triangle
yeah oh yes there's a documentary on
that and the thing that struck me most
about that was the Jim there was an
English journalist that was involved who
was flown over there and he was a sick
twisted piece of [__] because he was
basic like it was great he was a young
good-looking girl it probably killed
other people it sort papers for us and I
saw the guy who was you saying that in
the documentary yeah so this year mr.
sitting there sort of saying it's sex
you know actually I remember the
documentary a flood everything had
everything and what he meant was the
full story it was great for us
it was also great it was great from a
documentary telling perspective because
he was so he was actually he was almost
like such a raw faced [__] that you
were just sort of like you almost look
to him for I can't leave you saying and
in a way I did it was laughing all the
way spoke but the truth be told it was
such a great documentary it would no
other way I look at it was so many
journalists or this man yeah were
finding it and one of them actually act
and how they really are buying clothes
phone call sensitive insensitive for
example an [__] Journal basically do
you often do you often hear other
people's story told or in hearing other
people's stories or has there been any
sort of therapy or kind of help in
hearing what other people have been
through because you say a part of a
support group or you've been well I set
up a support group against some support
after murder manslaughter and well you
thought they helped me years ago cuz I
watched his crime it was trial and
retribution and I was disturbed this in
nineteen years after mama died I was
like I jumped out myself and I'm
pleading for this guy to stop killing
this woman it was like I was watching my
mom being killed in a
Samaritans and they put me in touch with
this organization that was many years
ago when I finally started turning the
corner I then contacted them as quick
listen can I help can i no sorry retrace
that they asked me to set up of a
support group in Leeds I said what do I
know
so you know everything so I did set up
this all waiting for about four or five
years where we would get together once a
month and I can't say that I was helped
by hearing their stories but I certainly
feel that they were helped by by knowing
that I'd been through something similar
and I was willing to listen to them
somebody made it to their forties
essentially but you know well I mean
there's some people older than me
because I've lost children but all I'm
saying is somebody 30 years later just
come through it and and understands they
just took some comfort from that
actually couple years ago I was asked to
go to Liverpool because this woman's son
had been killed wrong place wrong time
wasn't this boss to pay him and she
found a way to me and sizzle and I sat
with her when I was a Liverpool and sat
with there and they want to adopt me it
was beautiful but then you know just
sitting down with someone like that
so that because most people don't
appreciate what that feels like so for
them to sit down with some of that does
appreciate their pain that was just a
beautiful thing to do and you want one
thing we haven't covered is you are now
in a relationship and you've got a got
kids and mudded yeah I've got three
ginger kids don't you then he has a hint
of red in the little bike and genetics
may I be honest with you not [__] but
what I do want to talk about is you know
we've now got a really successful career
you're a public speaker yeah and how did
you get into that and what does that
entail when I wrote the book it was on
national TV and in particular radio for
Woman's Hour and somebody heard me share
my story ten minutes and said we've got
a conference coming up on my night to
come and share your story now bear in
mind like a luck like of confidence and
low self esteem throughout most of my
life I thought there is no way I'm gonna
do that but I thought again and you add
that lack of confidence so I thought if
I do it it might help me in some way so
I accepted I went along
an appalling job sat down in a chair I
read out on me book and it was the start
of that journey and that was 2005 and
then I became a Samaritan volunteer
myself and they had a conference they
said because I've written this book can
you come and speak I'm gonna need this
thing it was horrific and then somebody
put me in touch with I'll suggested of
drawing the professional speaking
Association I went along intimately
they're all there with the suits on and
little old me and I thought this could
be good for me and I realized there was
an industry where people are you know
inspirational speakers share their story
and I decided when the book came out
Wits University thought I'd get some
qualifications but because I was getting
these invitations to speak I made a
decision right know I want to change
tack all the money from a first book
little des some of the extended family
realized I spent all the money I'm going
to university cuz I Pat my job in so
there's nobody from the book left so but
I decided forget that write that off I'm
gonna become a speaker that was in 2006
I made the decision November the 4th of
November 2000 Saturday the 4th of
November at the belfry I saw a speaker
from America called W Mitchell I thought
oh my god blow me away I thought that is
what I should be doing and there are
some fantastic speakers because I've
gotten to watching some of them who's
that big giant guy but Bob Robin Tony
Robins Robins are seen in 2006 yeah he
he basically tries to break people down
and build them back up and all that and
like cut your [__] away but he
charges like thousands and thousands to
come in and and and I realized I was
like I mean obviously is very talent
he's very good at what he does but I
didn't realize it's it's a business yeah
and I realized that I thought you know
what I've got a message for the world
I've got a story like this guy I'm gonna
do this mm-hmm and I walked away from
you and Amy chuta said don't and I
thought no I'm gonna do that and you had
a story I was a crap speaker but I'll
just get some help get some coaching and
gain some confidence
I'll speak around the world now in two
thousand times over two thousand times
I'm speaking this afternoon in London
I've seen your TED Talks which was
fantastic for any other small well yeah
we can TEDx to eighteen minutes
but I mean this is this is the real deal
this is the best thing all right dude
check out yeah you've done a lot of good
talks like yeah I've been around a
little bit and I've learned the hard way
I made some mistakes and now I also do
presentation skills training I teach
people to do what we're doing now what
you just have a chat and a
conversational style but it's hard
though this is what people like the
thing is when you watch it it feels like
you're in the room and people are come
to the conversation but when you have to
get on stage I've had to do that a few
times and I think I'm quite naturally a
good speaker but it is a skill like my
performative thing is well you just got
to calm the nerves and that and you've
got you look out and there's all these
eyes on your net everyone sit all right
go on then there's all the cynics yeah
and then there's a few of them like up
to another five times I never normally
do that it's not a good speak but
there's a few of them who will be like
doubt me and it is quite you're in a lot
of pressure
wow you are and what I've got my sleeve
though is the the they don't normally
know what's coming right so because I
know I've got that and it's go surprise
them I'll just hit them but I'll get
I'll get lost cynics I'll win them over
within five minutes and once again
nothing's as bad as losing your mum so
you can conquer that the nervousness and
anxiety I suppose have been in front of
people is that one of the things that
you drew from initially well the thing
that the thing I gave me the courage to
be able to get up and what we have
skipped over incidentally is the first
time I go up which is when I was 13 at
school mate the public's what is my
English teacher I'm back in touch with
30 odd years later my English teacher
mr. Hill encouraged me to take part in
the public speaking competition I was
petrified but I found the courage to get
on I found the courage because I lost my
ball and I'm not lost no moment I found
the courage because I thought what cat
competitive losing your mom so I got on
there my dad raced pigeons a nice book
about pigeons and
after off coincidentally unlike
everybody else who had slides and HP
projectors and posters I had nothing I
just spoke like this the reason I said
it's coincidental is because for the 12
years I've been speaking I always your
slides this afternoon in London I'm
gonna talk without any slides whatsoever
it's going to take some guts but I have
to rely on the story and I think
in more detail and see how it goes but I
took a pigeon with me that was my only
prop and I'm on the competition and he
took a pigeon that was my only prop it
was in a basket
side of the stage and after I got a bit
more confident so excuse me got this
pigeon and they it was beautiful moment
about this big poster in my office which
was drawn from him fully enough by a
woman called Molly Molly was attached my
Peter so cliff and I helped her over the
phone over the years she'd become an
artist she drew me this big picture of
his it's a guy with a pigeon like that
it's because she knows how significant
it was and it was a significant moment
for me and I guess it was a seed that
was planted that you know blossomed all
these years lit and that's what I do
there are they're sort of weird strands
because you never would have known her
had you not been through that situation
no and so why why pigeons because I've
recently groper yes please grow up
around that and we look quite sort of
interpleader I had to feed them how do
you feed a bid to you so it drops and
you take a pigeon corn yeah I've got a
confession actually so my dad would
sometimes been working away and I'd say
like God get to a pound worth in money
of pigeon kansai go to the pigeon or the
pet shop and say three basileus yeah one
of the interviews you did on the way
down and when you said from day one
you're a little bit like that because
you'd go next door and you'd go and do
our shopping for and should give you
fifty pence or some sweets and that's me
and I thought me so I knew I was gonna
go me because I thought I know well I
don't know I thought it's a northern
thing but like the pigeons and all right
pigeons are like I would make cousins
had pigeons and then they had nothing
about that they had lots of ships and
you've gone round in like in the bucket
that just be like so many pigeons so I
remember driving around cuz if you live
in the Midlands like I did and you live
out sort of near the little town little
villages a lot of people do keep pigeons
there are the SHO pigeons so that so
they look good you taken two shows in
the window Awards and are they pretty
birds some of them I have to pay for
them more right or there
Racing horn pigeons and erase the exist
is a lot of plastic surgery in giant ass
you know love him yeah some shenanigans
bent on because what what your
competitors would do is they put a cat
in the loft that would kill the pigeons
you know some stuff went on really yeah
I'm so ever like the burger was like
pigeon wars and you knew that when they
would people come over put a cat in yeah
knock on the door and so I knew all
about the pigeons and I just basically
spoke about them and and I won the
competition did you do you like page it
a little bit of people probably going to
any other page yes this is a typical
Lauren subject I'm just saying no I mean
I find it quite compelling to find out
what people are driven by when make it
do you like pigeons then I like but I
like to see them have you got any
tattoos no yeah we got a toad you know I
hear when he first came in he said the
man with all the tattoos meets the
motels because I'm the tow person like I
like meaningful toys and stuff and if I
if I was you one day get yourself pigeon
no but I see pigeons now well might be
on holiday so when a pigeon all ten of
us oh that's my dad so you know I lost
my dad and yeah it's just a nice part of
my story yeah as a pigeon one thing I we
started down but and didn't really got
into because you speaking out of
speaking was losing your mum very young
he's obviously really difficult a lot of
people identify having a poor
relationship with your mother or not
having a relationship with your mother
as there for a reason maybe you were
going to these poor relationships and
women in your life mmm-hmm and we get a
lot of emails from young men on this
show maybe they only have one idea about
what kind of relationship they want and
they don't quite know how to maybe
change the way they act in relationships
so how did you go through all these poor
relationships or and what were those
problems and how are you now and what
you would consider to be a more healthy
relationship yeah I won't say that the
relationships were particularly poor
means somewhere unhealthy so maybe
something grow me that person but most
of them were reasonable but at NDI I'd
be like self-sabotage and
yeah subconscious that I'd find a way to
push them away so they'd leave because
deep down it was good enough so then I
got what I felt I was deserving off how
did that change I'm a matured but I got
the counselling I haven't since I got
two years of psychoanalysis and I don't
know helpful that was but I think it
must have been what is somewhat
psychosocial normals counselling is it
no it's not it's like so telling is like
we'll get together have a chat about
what's going on and kick things about
felt like I was talking to me mum really
good Sandra still still does it
but psycho analysis is where you
basically sit down on a sofa oh they
don't know what kind of bed honestly
nothing might get said for five minutes
right and then whatever is going on for
me I might just it might say like a
sentence and then you'd explore the
sentence and basically your brain would
bring to the fore what needs you're
discussing and it might be something
that you thought the night before or the
day or just now what really really deep
and I think if you go through something
really bad you need someone to do that
with you and whether it be a friend an
aunt and uncle what cousin whatever if
you'd gone through so long without doing
that it was always gonna have to happen
at some point sure you went through two
years two years of that and two and half
years of counseling so that's four or
five years and I'd still say that there
are still things that are not perfect
but if I say perfect you know I mean
there's there's still things that
affects me that I think are as a
consequence to what happened in my
childhood that the thing that I have to
battle with it is that it's that the
sensitive side to me like the comment
yesterday on face but where the girl
says know what to listen to you [__]
it's it's like a bit of criticism and I
have to kind of yeah or my head high and
move on from that but but because it's
like being criticized your kid and not
being worth nothing good I read when I
was obviously doing me research that um
you had to call the police or something
about someone tweeting your nasty things
as well as something like that Wow you
have dug deep Oh me um those ten pages
deep I'm good at what I do
Oh somebody wrote something about is
that a common thing to me
we I get trolled every now and then it's
like arts [__] because I'm just true
Geordi the youtuber it's not a big deal
but people will say things that they
feel are gonna hurt you the most on and
whatever they've got on you whether it's
you're a [__] youtuber they'll use that
or whatever they'll try and hurt your
feelings but to me there's a lion is it
normal for people to cross that line
no for you do you feel like people
respect that yeah I mean it's somebody
saying no once isn't listen to your
[__] that's just somebody in a
negative place this individual that went
to police about it was two years on now
it was a 40th anniversary of the night
moon when it was the 3rd of October two
years ago and I just admitted tweet on a
Facebook message saying you know what
it's quite a movie evening this evening
I was on the more to it service station
because it's 40 years ago tonight that
mum went out and this idiot wrote
something about I won't repeat what he
said cause it's - I mean it's not
important me Ponyboy basically said the
mum deserved what she got all right wait
waiting some much more detail than that
I fight you little [__] I'm not having
that
so I went to the police because it did
hurt me and disturbed me and I think
you've got every right before the police
personally is on the run now but not for
that it's on the run anyway hmm he is
now yeah so he got a court hearing in
Leeds and didn't turn up in the looking
for him hey-ho it must be yeah that's a
forgiveness thing I want you to meet the
guy at car and God you know what I'll
shake you and hope that you've learned
something through that but I'm not sure
I don't know if it comes but a little
thing is will they will there be anyone
on the other side of that hardened who
actually is aware of the level that
you're operating on because you're
enlightened at this point from all the
crap that you've been through but he's
obviously did not if you write and [__]
like that on the internet I don't think
you're on that main set no you're right
so it's like let him rot now obviously
here's a question for you mate you've
come out the other side you're really
successful now when you're doing great
I'm not sure of the how much you can
remember of your mum but how do you feel
she would feel now looking down on you
well I think she would feel proud but
the pause was influenced by the bloody
cynics out there that would think that
on try to be egotistical saying she'll
be proud if I was my father I would be
proud of my son
my son did some of the things that I've
done yeah I can generally say that I
think she's proud and I'd be proud of my
son how do you dealt with that thing
everyone would agree with that because
you know it would take a lot of people
don't know what you've been through
and and I think mainly proud about the
father that I've become and the family
that I've got a lot beautiful family and
then your son do some public speaking as
well it did say man up done me research
fella he was actually in the Canon no
last year my son when he was a was asked
by the teacher teaching assistant what
you wanna do when you're older they've
all been asked this so I went into the
parents evening and on the wall was some
little postcard I want to be a teacher I
want to be a fireman I want to be a
podcaster but my son was there with
these little white things saying when I
grow up I wanna be a motivational
speaker oh so much beautiful mm-hmm see
ya dad but they laughed at me now I
don't know how accurate that is we
should sit on a 20 and she's off I'm
gonna baby now but what I did is I gave
him the opportunity to start doing that
so I started bring him along to my
weekend events and I remember first Wady
I said so did I say a few words right
nor and they all laughed but I've got
him on stage the next one which is half
the battle yeah then the next one was I
thought that all three kids on the stage
could not to feel how I did as a kid and
then the next time I went to present it
at their presentation skills evening
I've got a long stage we're almost like
kind of staged it because I said just
give them some support
you stood only way if I can you can too
they gave him a standing ovation and we
just built on from that culminating in
him well actually the penultimate one
was him speaking to 15
teachers at the Leeds Arena which was
awesome hmm but the biggest one was at
the Echo Arena in Liverpool was to 3,000
people and he's now writing his own book
he's got his own website check out Ellis
McCann code so all these videos are on
there obviously cap contacting but these
little videos are there I'm travelling
powering so understand that you can do
anybody once and you're sort of motto in
these talks is about having that
attitude of you can do anything mostly I
can my name's Richard mechanics
obviously I can velocity I like the logo
I like the way that that's good and a
lot of people in the audience they seem
to get a lot from what you say to them
they do it there's so many different
level you said it there's so many levels
to my story and you know if you've met
me about my family [__] with the father
it mad about the abusive relation to
their own business you know there's lot
the summer levels to it people tend to
enjoy it and it does mean it takes a
really hard face cynical person to just
listen to that and think what was that
you know most people enjoy it you know
and yeah and well sharing it yeah so
great it is a great story and as hard as
it's probably been to go through at
times but it's it's good it's a good one
to share it like saying I get I get one
dated by people that have been either
read the books or been to a live event
all of red meat or watch me tynix and
when I get letters from people that say
that they I've got please I've got
letters from people in prison around the
world South Africa that the books found
its way there and they've been helped by
radio I dealt with you know what for
every one of those letters or posts or
tweets
again it means me mum's death wasn't in
vain she's helping people she has helped
people I think that myself that that
must be a really nice thing to take from
such an awful event is if good can come
from bad then you know you've done well
yeah where do you think you are now in
terms of your journey like where you
because it's clear there are questions
we've asked you where you you've still
you're so emotionally sort of wrapped up
in some of this stuff not in a sort of
showing weakness or a way but you know
you still take you through the steps
yeah
to where one day you'll I think you're
in my opinion looking at you know your
your emotional about story but it's it's
such an emotional thing that you've been
through it's impossible to just be
called
general I mean wait where do you see
yourself when we're if we imagine
there's a ladder and you started it on
the bottom and the tops up here do you
feel like you're somewhere in the middle
or on your journey you know I probably
I'd like to see in the middle hmm and
I'd like to think there's a few years
left in me and I'd like to think that
some more levels to my story I will
unpick and ways in which I share it that
you know maybe through a podcaster that
have yet to happen and so yeah I think
the similar to I do believe that a large
part of my journey we thought we spoke
about it is the forgiveness side of
things and how that is put out there
could I speak that forgiven if so when I
speak and share my thoughts share that
typically I did at the TEDx talk because
that was about the power of the spoken
word and it was still the spoken word of
Desmond Tutu that I felt forgiveness but
ordinarily his back his bank will talk
about forgiveness and I do think that's
a large part of what might be going on
for me going forward getting people to
think about forgiveness and not just
mean so much harmed you I'm not about in
general letting things go in the
workplace and all the little things up
like piss you off as well not not just a
massive thing like you've been through
but it is a great quality to have isn't
it yeah that emotional awareness thing
and lots for me to learn still and to
continue doing what I do and obviously
retiring Monday I'm becoming my son's
agent Lee I don't know there's a good
plan actually
Doris age six was also done it now
doesn't got our own website but she was
inspired by him so I've got this big
event called I can live and she spoke at
the last I can live in for the children
ten people round cabaret table so it's a
massive thing
and at the end she came on and she
almost company's words but she said it
you know anyway it was a beautiful thing
to see
mm-hmm well it's nice that you're giving
your kids and that 'true that they can
achieve anything in life because I was
given that and it's definitely helped me
not feel like to be intimidated and I
think more parents rather than putting
ceilings on the kids have what the kit
will have achieved and should be like
that and say oh you can do anything you
want and support that you know you're I
and we should um but there isn't just
children that need to hear that I think
you know a lot of society models need to
understand that we shouldn't be
intimidated by the chief executive or
the managing director or the doctor you
know we're all just people oh dear
and I don't know when that point was
that I I realized that and it's been
throughout my speaking journey but there
was a point where now I can't go have a
meeting with the chief exec and I don't
know that you've got some fears I don't
know that you've got problems at all and
I know that there's something happening
at you we're all made of similar stuff
we spoke about this a few podcast but
where I had that experience when I came
to London and I started mixing with
people who I thought were the bigwigs
with the world then I realized you know
actually a lot of these people I've got
a [__] clue what they're doing most
the time you seen behind the door isn't
it yeah exactly
whereas you get to directly talk to them
and deliver the message I suppose so you
you work that out over the years so it
must also be great because there is in
many ways they're there to see you talk
as opposed to the other way around when
I didn't necessarily mean speaking to
events I don't just mean people yeah
just you know differently reversal the
dynamic that normally you know a CEO is
not me the person you want to go and
talk to whereas now is they want to come
and hear what you have to say so some of
the some of them do do you have any
remaining questions remain nice been
it's been fascinating but I've got one
more question I usually like to ask at
the end which is how would you like to
be remembered
what a nice question I think I'd like to
be remembered as the son of Wilma McCann
that bounce back and recovered having
experienced that and went on to affect
countless people by sharing that story
well me I think there's not a doubt in
mind that you've done that sort of well
done pal you're already there can you
tell on the recording we'll just say you
know not the cameras oh no all right
you know I have to say I was Arden
giving the gift I thought they all bring
you presents sometimes they do but I
feel I'm indeed I take him as so many
support he gets the New Castle me what
are the colors black and white my friend
[Laughter]
loves them that is not just a fidget
spinner
it's an you can see your colors I want
you to spin that and tell me if you
don't want it I'm taking it back for a
spin that lies mate tell him that's not
genuinely you just made my day thank you
very much he's clearly on the bus that
may thanks very much and also I want to
say thank you to the followers on
Twitter because they were the ones who
recommended this and I often ask people
can you recommend me people that get on
the podcast and I said because I already
know about the youtubers and I say
specifically not footballer YouTube and
I still get football and YouTube people
suggested but someone along the lane
said you I can't remember that any I'm
sorry but individual is hit twice and I
must check back and see who it is but I
followed up on that and then we spoke
and I agreed I'd I thought I better look
into what he does it's good when you
follow us they know what would work so
they have obviously spend enough time
watching us now to know oh this is a
good good podcast or so a real pleasure
yeah I've really enjoyed this hopefully
use a lot have to if you have make sure
hit that like button to subscribe thanks
for watching and we'll see you later